[Music]
kevin welcome the show how are you doing
man very good thank you very much
hey so you are uh in washington right
now that's why you're all suited up and
looking spiffy what's uh the
conversation in in washington what are
you there to do well as you know the
llamas bill has dropped a couple of
hours ago it's been long awaited this is
a bipartisan effort
very important it sets some parameters
around whether you know chains or
commodities or securities it
contemplates all kinds of different
attributes such as stable coins and it's
important to get this off the ground
this dialogue has been sorely needed but
it's not the only bill there's also the
hagerty bill the toomey bill uh other
initiatives going on so you've got a lot
of of policy makers finally addressing
this issue
but for the first time basically knowing
that there's a huge institutional demand
waiting to get involved when they
finally bring policy forward and and i'm
just here to be part of it there's many
private citizens involved
it's important to get to washington
important to talk to these leaders
important to give your ideas
they're basically
soliciting the industry and i think
that's important
well kevin thank you for for being there
and representing all of our interests
and the interests of the crypto industry
as a whole i just want to pick your
brain a little bit more about uh how you
are trying to move the needle yourself
off yeah you see uh cynthia alumni and
the bill cynthia lummus and the bill is
exactly the kind of legislation that we
need to promote the merits of this
crypto industry i i'm wondering like uh
what do you think that you can help do
when you are in washington and how are
you helping move the needle there
so you know what what i'm suggesting and
i'm just one voice but but i try and say
this over and over again to policymakers
is let's pick one thing
i mean the crypto universe is so broad
it's so huge there's so many different
things going on at the same time let's
bring policy on one thing and get that
done and what i'd like that to be is
stable coins because as a payment system
right now
it would be very very productive to
bring forward some policy on stable
coins and let the market compete now i
personally prefer ones that are backed
by hard assets like the us dollar but
there's many ideas out there some work
some don't obviously what happened with
luna was a bad outcome but that's okay
this is an ineos in industry and we're
trying different ideas but the desi the
need for an international payment system
is so
huge and so
it's such a huge opportunity to save
costs to provide transparency
auditability liquidity speed all of
those things that's what i'm suggesting
let's pick one thing and bring policy on
stable coins let's nail that and then
we'll move into bitcoin we'll move into
blockchain we'll move into other things
but nfts but let's nail one thing that
would feel good for uh congress to kind
of nail thing nail one thing it's been
largely silent on crypto like we've had
no clarity in this space and i'm curious
since you're there in washington cabin
you're kind of plugged into some of
these circles a lot of people in the in
the crypto industry the crypto natives
of the world are are somewhat skeptical
of washington like you mentioned
washington you mentioned congress and
they just kind of recoil like we don't
need government sort of thing uh we're
more on the side of you know we want
governments to bring forward uh sensible
regulations so that not not that um yeah
so that america won't miss out on crypto
and they won't miss out on defy and all
of the innovation not for the sake of d5
but for the sake of the united states
let me ask the question as you're in
washington you're looking at the senator
lummus legislation some other
legislation are you optimistic that
they're going to get it right like do
they actually understand crypto this
time what do you what do you make of
this bill and similar efforts
they don't need to get it right they
just need to get it in other words we've
got to move forward on something here
and i'll tell you why for all of the
people in the crypto universe and there
are many that don't think we need
regulation let me point something out
that would get everybody on board it's a
very simple quantum mathematics and
here's how it works
the majority of invested capital on
earth is held by sovereign and pension
plans about 90 plus percent of it they
own zero crypto nothing and so for all
the excitement about bitcoin 800 billion
that is absolutely a giant nothing
burger it is totally irrelevant it's not
held by any institutions that matter now
i'm an indexer and i've talked about
this many many times in there's many
indexers in the world but we cert we
service sovereign funds pension plans
let's say you're an oil-rich country in
the middle east you're making 250
million cash a day us dollars in oil
revenues you don't want to reinvest in
oil you want to invest in every other
sector so they'll go to an indexer like
me and say index the s p 500 less energy
less airlines that's the kind of index
we do and i and so we see these fund
flows trillions of dollars of fund flows
every year just going through the system
indexers see that every 24 hours and i
always ask these institutions and these
sovereign funds what allocation would
you put into bitcoin just one bitcoin
which is the granddaddy digital asset
everybody knows that what would you
allocate if you could and they said well
we can't because our compliance
department won't allow it because the
sec hasn't ruled on it yet and larry
fink doesn't like it and he's our
biggest money manager and all those
other reasons but
they would allocate 50 to 100 basis
points now when you're running a
trillion dollar mandate or 800 billion
dollar mandate which is some of the size
of these funds that's a ton of money and
that's a huge amount of demand that
would come into the market and as
bitcoin prices went past that one
percent allocation let's say they'd sell
it back down to one percent but just
importantly if it dropped below one
percent they'd buy it back up so there'd
be an internal bid forever the
volatility would drop dramatically
there'd be price appreciation in bitcoin
it would be good for everybody involved
in crypto but we can't do it without
policy and so everybody should just get
off this let's be rogue let's be crypto
cowboys forget all that crap it's time
to get this real and get a tremendous
amount of capital going into crypto
because it's policy and it gets
regulated and it's good for everybody
kevin you talked to so many people
across the whole world the whole
landscape of investors and and
regulators and uh i've actually i've
been keeping an eye on on your
trajectory in the crypto space going
from the 2017 skeptic to the 2021 bowl
uh and i'm wondering as you are now
talking to so many people and as the
world becomes peaked by crypto and
interested in crypto what's your
generalized pitch for for why crypto is
here to stay why crypto's good whether
you're giving it to a legislator on
capitol hill or a hedge fund manager
with a billion dollars in their
portfolio
why crypto why is crypto good and what
do you have as like a generalized pitch
for people
because the largest economy on earth is
financial services i think crypto will
be the 12th sector of the economy within
10 years because it adds so much
liquidity so much productivity so much
transparency so much auditability it's
so much better than what we're doing
right now which is so expensive and so
slow if i want to transfer capital over
to zurich to buy nestle stock and swiss
francs it takes me days and it costs me
a fortune and it's incredibly
inefficient i could do it in two seconds
with a stable coin and i can't yet
because we don't have policy on both
sides of the ocean that let me do that
but it's coming one day and i think
crypto and blockchain and the services
and financial transactions
microtransactions all of it are going to
lend itself to this blockchain
auditability
transparency the ledger system it all
makes sense to me and i think regulators
are starting to figure that out now as
an investor
i don't know which of these chains is
going to win is solana going to be
polygon should i be in poland what about
you know all of the others ethereum of
course the big one right now but too
slow for many many financial services
what's going on with you know helium and
all of these different ideas out there
so my strategy is to do the same thing i
do with stocks get diversification i own
32 positions 32 chain projects 32
different coins and tokens i have no
idea which ones will win over the next
five years but i don't need them all to
win i just need a few to win and that's
what diversification is all about and
i've made some investments in the
infrastructure you know that old adage
and the gold rush you were better owning
and selling picks and shovels and jeans
than you were trying to find gold
because that was very hard to do the
infrastructure
of crypto our companies like ftx i'm a
shareholder circle i'm a shareholder
wonderful i'm a shareholder immunible
holdings i'm a shareholder i've given
money to all of these projects because
they make a lot of sense to me and i use
them all and they're centralized
decentralized there's stable coins in
there there's the ftx platform which is
the first compliant institutional
platform i can find that my auditors and
my compliance department finally agree
to let me use to store value and these
are those are the kind of things that
really matter to me and i have to
disclose yes i'm a shareholder in ftx
i'm also a paid spokesperson so i'm you
know i'm eating my own cooking but i'm
also talking about the merits of their
compliance platform
yeah kevin so i'm interested in that
that that comment you just made i like
them and i use them all all right so
here's the position of of so many in
washington so many of our lawmakers so
many that are kind of outside the crypto
space is probably similar to your
position in 2017 your your
pre-conversion uh position on crypto
which is like i like i don't understand
this like what i i don't even like it
seems like a bubble it's i don't know
what your your takes were back in 2017
but i know you were bearish you were
negative can you talk as somebody who
has been converted who has started to
use these products in your everyday life
can you speak to that skeptic what what
do you tell the skeptics in dc or
in the finance space or you know the the
thinks of the world what do you what do
you tell them about crypto how do you
how do you explain it how do you
convince them so i'm an investor i'm
constantly trying to find a way the path
of least resistance to invest my capital
redeploy it i have to look around the
world for opportunities i have to be
diverse and you know crypto to me when
it was being frowned up upon by
regulators in a very harsh way if you
recall 2017 was probably the height of
when regulators were cramping clamping
down on tokens and different ways to to
to tokenize assets like hotels and
everything else back then and as a
result i'm so involved in the
traditional financial services market
where i'm highly regulated and i have to
report almost monthly to both my
internal auditors compliance department
and external regulators all around the
world that that's the world i'm used to
and i saw no relief coming from
regulators and then what turned me
around what changed me completely was
when the canadians the osc granted the
very first crypto exchange license
attached to a dealer broker a compliant
platform it wasn't rogue anymore they
told canadian citizens you can transfer
your cash out of your bank into this
centralized wallet and you can trade
ethereum bitcoin and slowly more and
more coins were added
then they announced in canada the very
first bitcoin etf then they announced
the very first etf that was for ethereum
they were moving forward with policy
that was regulated and i immediately
started investing in that because i saw
it coming i saw the writing on the wall
and i've also made the assumption this
is a personal assumption that the osc
the regulator that granted that world
order for the first time a dealer broker
was well in touch with the sec and other
regulators around the world they talk to
each other every day maybe canada was
being used as a petri dish or an
experiment to try it and it's been
wildly successful that's when i got
involved in wonderful i became a
shareholder there wonder if i bought bit
by which was the first regulated
exchange and now that company has 800
000 registered compliant crypto accounts
it's the model for the rest of the world
so i got on a plane i went to united
arab emirates switzerland england south
america and i started showing these
different regulators look what the
canadians are doing can we do the same
thing here and that's exactly how i'm
spending my time now trying to open up
these new markets with the policies that
have been put in place tested and proven
and proven to work in canada
it's always wonderful to see just the
well-informed investors of the world uh
with with
insane like uh respect and renownedness
from their communities go down the
crypto rabbit hole and turn into into
crypto evangelists and kevin i i was
watching a podcast you did with uh uh
our friend anthony pompliano uh where
apparently uh earlier earlier in your
guys relationships uh he said that he
had 50 of his portfolio in bitcoin and
you thought he was absolutely crazy for
that uh but that was before you we uh
really went down the crypto rabbit hole
so i'm wondering over the years as we've
gone into like the 2020 to 2021 bull
market but now into the 2022 bear market
how your portfolio allocation into
crypto has changed is it is it been like
up only as in more and more crypto
exposure over time or has it gone back
and forth as the markets have changed
how are you 50 yet kevin yeah 50 50 or
plus no i basically what's happened to
me is i've been layering in now for 36
months i started at two and a half
percent went to seven then we went past
15. now in portfolio theory if you're
running you know a mandate such as a
sovereign fund let me give you the rules
by which those big boys play and i'm
using the same philosophy for crypto we
have 11 sectors in the s p 500 portfolio
theory would tell you never more than 20
in any one sector never more than five
percent in anyone's stock or bond that's
diversification and that's basically how
99 of sovereign wealth is managed by
indexers like me and many others are
like me and so i've done the same thing
in crypto i've said okay i think crypto
will be the 12th sector of the economy
in 10 years i'm going to treat it that
way now in the operating company that
means i can put up to 20
of our operating capital into the crypto
space and then i want diversification so
i've basically done exactly that my
largest holdings right now are ethereum
and bitcoin that's not a big surprise
but i also have a big position
in in usdc big position in ftx as an
equity which is a private company and
then on down polygon i got involved with
sandeep i liked his story i met him in
dubai you know trying to reduce gas fees
on top of ethereum makes a lot of sense
for india and other countries like that
like what he's doing i bought a piece of
that love what's going on in all in the
serum project solana i'm a big fan of
what you know sam backmanfred is doing
these things all make sense to me but in
the you know in the proportions of
diversification now that portfolio i'd
say about eight weeks ago was at 21 now
it's down at about 18 there's been a big
correction in the market but you've got
to hold your nose and get used to the
volatility and it let me it lets me just
positions i can add a little bit to my
usdc
my compliance department does doesn't
consider usdc
a money market or or a proxy for cash
they consider it a highly volatile
equity that's because of what's been
going on in stablecoin so i'm limited to
a five percent waiting there and i'm
trying to get some policy while i'm here
in washington remember we go right back
to that give me one thing just give me
policy on stable coins and let the
market compete and i could put a lot
more into that space because i've got a
lot of cash on my operating company
balance sheets and i have nowhere to put
it and inflation is six seven eight
percent and i'm getting 45 basis points
in a bank that's really crazy i could do
a lot more with stable coins so that's
funny so you're saying even compliance
is trading usdc which is a stable coin
which is one-to-one pretty much
one-to-one backed with money in a bank
actual dollars in a bank you're saying
that they're still treating that as a
speculative asset so that's the
challenge that's a challenge you can't
get your compliance department on board
because they say show me the policy well
there is no policy that's the problem is
it fdic insured we don't have that yet
we've really got to get this stuff
nailed down that's why i keep telling
everybody get behind policy because
you're going to get a whole lot more
capital into this space there's 52
billion already in usdc tethers out
there that broke a buck so i can't touch
that and of course luna was insanity
well we now know algorithmic based
stable coins well they don't work so
well do they so the market will figure
that out
and they'll
and they'll basically adjust accordingly
based on risk and return
so there's a number of different ways to
get upside exposure in the crypto
industry and i would imagine that you
take every single way that you deem
legitimate and like some of the easiest
ways obviously are just buying the
crypto monies like ether bitcoin which
you said i think are your perhaps your
biggest exposures but there's like other
strategies too like yield farming with
stable coins uh but then there's also
buying crypto equities like ftx or coin
stock but then there's also
angel investments and private private
market investments and i'm wondering how
you weight all of these things and if
there's any other categories that i miss
that that are worth mentioning as well
just how do you weight these things with
your attention and with your capital
well obviously when new projects come to
market i'm very fortunate i see pretty
well every deal and there's a reason for
that there's a direct correlation
between market capitalization and
telling the company's story everybody
knows i have millions of followers
millions of investors and i like to talk
about the cooking i eat i mean i don't
invest in projects that i don't use i
don't care whether it's a product or
it's a crypto product or whatever you
don't see me in a lot of these very
speculative tokens because i don't use
them i'm looking for value there i'm
intrigued by the nft market in
authentication of physical assets around
the watch industry that's a space i'm
very involved in that's a private
investment along with other giant
collectors and watch makers and
horological societies but that's just my
personal interest so it's the things
that i really that i really want to dig
into that i invest in but you're right
there's a lot of room for private
projects because
you know i look at it this way you talk
to any grad coming out of mit or
waterloo or temple or mcgill or any of
these really high-end engineering
colleges and universities and a third of
the engineers all want to go onto the
blockchain you can't take that much
intellectual capital and not expect some
incredible outcomes three to five years
from now so you want to invest in some
of these people these are the smartest
hands over keyboards all around the
world they're not working for the
traditional industries they're on the
chain and that means there's going to be
a lot of productivity there that's what
you want to bet on it's like betting on
steve jobs when he was just drawing
fonts with a felt pen that kind of idea
it's the same thing going on now these
guys are going to be big productivity
for the economy and you've got to put
your money behind them
but some people will say kevin uh but
look at the bear market okay the bubble
just burst they'll point to luna of
course but then they'll even point to
bitcoin right now which is down 60
percent ethereum down 65 percent the
solana's in the and the polygons of the
world down 85
plus and they'll and they'll say look uh
you know this asset space is too
volatile normal investors you know
shouldn't get exposure to this space
it's it's too risky all of these things
some some will even say as this bear
market continues i'm sure that uh that
crypto is dead the way they said that in
2018 and 2019 what's your response to
those kind of criticisms and should we
be concerned about the bear market i
think i read a quote by the way uh kevin
would you you called it nightmarish and
i think for people it's their first time
on the merry-go-round here the crypto
merry-go-round this is a ride for them
that they don't want to be on they're
starting to get nauseous what's uh what
are your thoughts on the bear market and
what do you tell people about this
well you know i i give an example that
everybody can relate to because in the
early years of amazon 18 years ago i was
a shareholder both in the equity and in
the preference shares they used to have
in those days that stock corrected every
12 to 18 months between 38 and 58
every single year over and over and over
again people just couldn't get their
heads around what amazon was doing and
it continued that way for a decade it's
no different than what's going on right
now
with bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
because there's no institutional demand
yet for the product people keep saying
institutions are involved but they're
not not at all and so if we get one of
these bills passed here in washington
which is why i'm here i would love to
see this agenda item move forward so it
can be decided on after the midterms i'm
sure biden's very very busy on other
issues right now but this isn't going
away and these senators and congressmen
and women know this and that's why
they're bringing these and advancing
them all of these senators are all over
cable tv today talking about this bill
dropping and it's not the only one and
certainly many of them will be
discussing it in the weeks ahead but the
point is as an investor do you want to
be ahead of this or behind it because i
think what happens is you get a binary
increase in the value of crypto the
minute people even sense policy and
that's going to happen sometime jan feb
march and so i want to be positioned
before then you don't have to but i
think it's the way to go in terms of
being early and niacin it's like being
involved in the internet in its most
early days same thing is going on here
long term it's a great investment but
boy
volatility yeah it's tough fifty percent
up fifty percent down sixty percent
swings well
that was amazon 12 15 years ago now it's
bitcoin today
what would you say are the obstacles
preventing good legislation from getting
through in capitol hill uh like why
isn't this a slam dunk because if you're
in the crypto space like we're just
asking for like very basic good
legislation and from our perception it's
obvious what needs to happen and this
says there's some crazy low-hanging
fruit things like stable coins perhaps
not being securities that seem so
trivial what's getting in the way like
who's getting in who's presenting
obstacles for us like why can't we just
have a slam dunk legislation around
crypto clarity
one word education
this is the most misunderstood sector of
the economy that's ever existed because
of the complexity of how it works
basically
policy makers do not understand it and
when you don't understand something you
tend to mistrust it it requires
education it's taken me years and a lot
of hours of reading and a tremendous
amount of travel to get to the place
where i'm comfortable making these
investments now and understand how this
works but that's not easy to do and and
the whole idea of a centralized and
decentralized wallet
very many people don't understand the
differences between it and yet you need
both in the crypto environment you
really want both one of the biggest
investment thesis i have about investing
in wonderful was it gave me both there's
a decentralized wallet there's a
centralized wallet and i don't want to
lose those customers if all of a sudden
you started by setting yourself up on
bit by which is the canadian
regulated centralized wallet and all of
a sudden you decided you want to have a
decentralized wallet with your nfts in
it i don't want to lose you as a
customer i spent hundreds of dollars
acquiring you i want to offer both with
a know your customer platform that
provides the compliance and that's what
they're building up there in canada and
that software itself and all the
millions of dollars of development
they're doing is going to be cookie
cutter for other markets like
potentially the middle east or south
america or switzerland or england that's
the whole idea of being part of these
things and pushing these projects
forward but it's education that's
holding everybody back we've got to
simplify this stuff most people the
first time that try and set up a
decentralized walk on let's say metamask
lose their money because they don't know
about security of the passphrase and
that's an important lesson to learn and
that's why i tell people start with 200
don't go crazy figure this stuff out
slowly learn about security learn about
password protocols learn about
centralized versus decentralized
check it out slowly
baby steps into it then you can put up
real money
so what is your advice for someone who
wants to get educated is it just that
you have to you have to start using
these applications i mean i i think a
lot of people
in the early days of the internet didn't
understand the internet until the first
time you know they typed in a google
search or they received an email or
something like that that's how the
internet was propagated what's your
advice for someone who's new to crypto
and wants to get started is it just
start using these protocols how did you
school up on it kevin
it was really out of need i mean
usdc for example and what circle has
done with their corporate accounts you
know i was very early on that platform
uh spent a lot of time with management
talking about how we could make this
work with compliance departments how we
could make it work with audit firms
because the first thing that happens
when you take a new asset class and you
call up your auditor or your regulator
or your compliance department say look i
want to transfer five percent of our
cash into usdc they say what
where's the compliance infrastructure
that marks to market that at four
o'clock when the market ends i said
there is no market end for crypto
there's no beginning there's no end it's
just trading 24 7. and there's no
infrastructure and that that is very
uncomfortable
when your compliance department is used
to just looking at your mark to market
positions at 401 and saying hey that
position is a six percent waiting it's
got to get sold down to five tomorrow
morning or you put too much leverage on
that position that's how the world works
we don't have the infrastructure yet and
so i tell people look start
slowly now for me usdc has become a very
powerful payment system many and more
and more time is going by inventors are
willing to take it i'm willing to take
it when people want to pay me for goods
and services in other countries i say
give me usdc if you're allowed to don't
ach me any capital out of a bank don't
send me swiss francs euros or british
pounds that's just a total headache for
me go figure out usdc and i'll take the
risk myself on it but you know that's
going to take a long time to happen i
tell everybody this is the future of
currency it's the future of payment
systems it's the 12th sector the economy
get over it and start learning about it
you know before the pandemic if you were
65 years old sitting in a condo in miami
beach and you never used your phone to
order groceries well now you do because
otherwise you would have starved to
death you couldn't go to the grocery
store you figured out how to download
one of those apps and start ordering
food and now you're totally hip to it
and you live your life on your phone
and that was because you had to the same
thing's going to happen in
cryptocurrencies kevin i just got to say
man i love that you're in the space like
on behalf of david and i've been doing
crypto education doing this podcast for
a long time and you are reaching an
entirely different demographic than than
we will and it's so cool to have you
saying the same thing using different
words and reaching other people about
this and i think that's your skill set
it's really uh telling stories and
spreading a narrative i'm curious where
you see your brand the you know the mr
wonderful kevin o'leary brand in crypto
what do you hear what are you here
trying to do is to spread awareness
you're trying to build product what's uh
what's your brand in crypto going to be
my brand is about compliance my brand's
about institutions my brand's about
allocation and diversification about
investing and so i'm able to have those
conversations with regulators they know
me already i can get the meeting in any
country in the world i can meet the head
of the of a bank in the middle east and
sit down with the ceo and say look
here's a compliance strategy to bring
your world into crypto let's work
together because i'm a hundred percent
compliant i am not a crypto cowboy i'm
talking about bringing the real money
into crypto the real sovereign wealth
and so for everybody that used to
criticize me about saying let's get this
thing regulated now they understand why
they want to get it regulated too it's
the trillion dollars that'll come into
this market overnight when it's
regulated and i'm just one of those
people out there trying to make that
happen and so yes it's baby steps but if
you're sitting down with the head of a
bank that's got five million accounts
and a trillion dollars sitting in those
accounts they're not interested in being
a crypto cowboy either they don't want
to be offside with their regulator they
want to work on a compliant basis and
make sure their internal compliance is
completely 100 percent nailed down so
they can report to their regulator and
not be offside
that's the kind of people i want to work
with that's what my brand's about and i
am on that
mission if you want to call it that for
the benefit of everybody in crypto
because if we can get this policy nailed
down
everybody benefits everybody values go
up i'll bring that to the table
everything goes up in value because the
real money will come in i alluded to
earlier how you were skeptical about
crypto in 2017 2018 which really makes
sense because that era of crypto was
really just the wild west uh famously
you know we call ours many people in the
crypto industry crypto djinns like
crypto degenerates they're gambling all
their money they're not paying attention
to securities laws uh but now going into
2020 and beyond like we have actually
figured out fundamental utility that has
attracted fundamental investors like
yourself into this space uh and i think
what you're telling me kevin is that
crypto is ready to really grow up and
really get mature uh and really start
bringing in capital from people who
would have been turned off by the wild
west of 2017 and 2018 but are turned on
by the more sustainable yields the more
sustainable utilities and use cases that
crypto brings and you alluded to it a
little bit but i'd like you to go into
it a little bit more you know prices go
up when crypto matures because it brings
in not just you know billions of capital
but trillions of capital from from all
over the world can you just picture give
us that paint that picture of crypto in
2023 and 2024 as we get regulatory
clarity as we get more comfortable with
with uh bigger institutions why is this
good for the crypto industry and why
does it need to happen for us make us
bullish kevin well look i'm going to lay
it out the way i see it and the way i'm
investing all right what's going to
happen is nothing before the midterms
but we're getting close
after the midterms when the house is
settled and who knows what it'll look
like but i have a pretty good idea we're
going to get some policy in the first
policy in my opinion personal opinion
here is going to be around stable coins
and here's what it's going to look like
it's going to be an open competitive
market just like you can find a money
market at schwab or a money market at
fidelity or a money market at some other
financial institution that are slightly
different
you know
stable coins are payment systems but
they're also stores of value if you're
willing to stake them out you can make
four and a half percent on an annualized
basis on a 30-day contract today right
now on usdc and other stable coins but
here's the policy i see coming it's
going to look like this
30 day audit on the assets underneath it
you can bring any kind of stable coin
you want but there's going to be a 30
day audit and what's in there no assets
supporting the token or coin with a
duration more than 12 months so if
you're going to use t bills they got to
be short duration probably average of
six months duration and that's very much
like a money market is run and
completely fdic insured there may even
be one or two of these stable coin
operators that apply to become a bank
and become fdic insured in which case
they would get trillions of dollars and
the reason this is going to happen first
why the stable coin market will happen
first with policy makers here in
washington is that it perpetuates the u
s dollar as the default currency of the
globe
when we get that worked out the u s
dollar becomes king dollar in perpetuity
even other countries even other
sovereigns are willing to bring tokens
out back by the us dollar because they
know in terms of attracting people to
use them and store them and save them
they got to have the king dollar and
this is why policymakers should get off
their you-know-whats and get this thing
done because we don't want the chinese
doing that with the one i would never
buy the chinese one as a stablecoin why
because i know they're watching it i
don't want them watching my dollars and
i don't trust that currency i trust the
us dollar so i wouldn't like to find out
the swiss franc did that before us we
got to get this thing done and make the
us dollar king dollar all around the
world everybody will be happy with a
product that is backed by the us dollar
one to one is liquid transparent you can
transfer immediately with a full ledger
and finally i could say to my compliance
department look
we finally have policy let me go to a
ten percent waiting in this as opposed
to locking me down at five and they
probably could get there because they
may consider it a cash equivalent at
some point
very similar to money market accounts
that very rarely break a buck that's the
whole idea and that's what will happen
next then we'll get policy on bitcoin
then we'll get policy on other chains
okay we'll start to debate is you know
solana a commodity or solana security
what about the nfts one by one will
knock these puppies down and that's the
way it should be but we don't want to
try and solve everything all at once
we'll never get it done we'll never get
it done one thing at a time let's start
with stable coins if you like that video
waiting you see my next one don't forget
to click right over here and subscribe